outrage à une personne dépositaire de
l'autorité publique
le tribunal correctionnel de dijon
examine aujourd'hui les agressions
verbales subie par marie-claude tuerie
ya la maire de bagnols petite commune de
côte-d'or a été violemment prise à
partie par un de ses administrés
bénéficiaire d'un logement communal
les faits remontent à avril 2010 est un
traumatisme pour les lieux soutenu par
une trentaine de maires venus à
l'audience aujourd'hui je suis
aujourd'hui dans un état de stress qui
qui explique le fait que j'ai été quand
même menacé et insulté d'une manière
très violente et bien sûr forcément j'ai
cela a porté atteinte à ma dignité de
mer faut dire que j'ai été blessé au
plus profond de moi-même et avec la peur
au ventre
je pense que c'est vraiment l'un portant
des traitements que ce soutien
je pense qu'on peut pour molester
inverse dans la vie tous les jours on
est là pour faire le job
on a été élu pour faire le job et on est
là pour faire à se respecter les lois de
l'état et les lois des communes donc
voilà on fait notre travail et je pense
qu'il faut que les citoyens respectent
impact elle même quand les décisions
vont dans leur sens l'audience est
actuellement en cours un compte rendu
détaillé ce soir dans notre édition de
19 heures